welcome to my mind firstly apologies now
let's go
[Music]
well it presents with a symmetrical
ascending weakness
which starts from the meat and moves up
the body
there will be reduced reflexes
i live in london that's coupled with the
fact that i tend to oversubscribe to
things
all the time and i am quite emotionally
sensitive means that i live
quite a hectic life in general and i am
very often in a state of overwhelm
because i naturally find it quite
difficult
to switch off my thinking or emotional
brain in those rare cases where i
am not thinking of deadlines and the
messages i need to answer and all the
things i need to do
i feel a state of complete emotional
bliss and peace that i just cannot
describe and so
being a natural constant overthinker i
appreciate
feeling absolutely nothing so much
so if this sounds like something you can
relate to in this video i am going to go
through four
ways in which i try to switch off my
brain and stop overthinking and the
reasons for which i do this
let's get straight into it number one is
isolation tanks or floatation tanks or
sensory deprivation tanks the thing with
these is that they are actually the most
effective method of switching off for me
however there is a few problems to them
because they're not easily accessible
for everyone they actually cost a lot of
money so i can't go to them very often
and they're just not very easy to find
and go to as the other methods
so i wanted to mention them very first
because they're so effective
but if you think you can or never want
to use them you can just skip ahead so i
first heard about isolation tags from
joe brogan and
amidst all of the sometimes not so
suitable for me things that he
recommends
i thought that flotation tanks were
actually something that i would be
willing to try so basically what they
are
is a room which has a big bath with a
lid on it
and inside the bath there is like water
and a lot of
salts and you just get completely naked
and you get in this bath and you close
the lid above you
so when you just lie in this water
because it has so much salt you're
basically completely
like lifted and it is absolutely dark
and completely silent
so you have complete sensory deprivation
where you're
lying down kind of like spread eagles
and because the water is so heavy and
the air is so dense you can't actually
tell where the water ends
and when the air finishes so it
literally feels like you are floating in
the middle of nowhere
and you can't see or hear anything so
it's completely
just silent it feels like you're just
floating out in space and although they
probably sound like torture chambers to
people with claustrophobia
to whom i would definitely not recommend
ever going there to everyone else
i think they are incredibly cool i found
them very interesting because
in the first 10 minutes i thought okay
this is really ridiculous what am i
doing here
and i was doing the same thing that i
always do when i try to meditate
which is trying to kind of stop thinking
but
i'm not really accomplishing that
because what i would be doing is just
kind of
think about my to-do list and what i had
to do later in the day and how the salts
will get out of my hair
and random things like that but in 10
minutes because it had
nothing to kind of feed me further so i
didn't have my phone to check to kind of
answer that email
or i didn't have my computer there i
just ran out of things to think about
and i got into this kind of what i think
i could describe as a deep deep
meditation state i don't think i've ever
felt more grateful to be
alive and more appreciative of the
things i have than
during flotation time experiences so i
think that they
are absolutely incredible especially if
you are struggling with meditation i
would definitely definitely recommend
going to one because they can be so so
useful to kind of shove you in a
complete
meditation state and they're actually a
whole experience and very very fun
i wish that they were cheaper and more
accessible because i would be going to
them very
very often i think another value in
isolation tanks is that they
kind of completely detach you from the
world you feel so isolated and shut out
that i feel as though you can approach
the issues and problems and things that
you are going on in your life
with a kind of objective
view that the real world in your natural
environment just doesn't allow you to do
so i feel like whenever i have a big
decision to make or if i'm feeling quite
sad
i just like to go to a flirtation tank
and kind of detach myself from
everything and realize that the world is
actually so beautiful and i'm grateful
so
for so much and i just feel so much
better in the end the second way i kind
of shut my mind off
is using water and this might be a bit
ridiculous i don't
know if anyone else thinks this way too
but ever since i was very very young
i just really really loved big spaces of
water
like especially the sea but even rivers
and things like that i just feel like
looking at
water or waves or kind of ripples is so
so so mesmerizing and i can do it for a
very long time and most importantly
it just helps me feel very very small
and insignificant
and i just love that feeling i feel as
though a lot of issues
and planning and thinking in my mind
comes from the thought that what i am
doing is very
important and i think that that is a
terrible thought to have in general i
read this phrase in one of my favorite
books time enough for love
that said something along the lines of
the higher up that someone is
the more that they need to forget it off
duty i feel as though now that i've
gotten older i've fallen into all of
these
different roles both in my professional
and personal life
so for example i'm someone's older
sister i am
a welfare lead and i need to take care
of students and i'm
a healthcare professional so i need to
act a certain way in hospital
and i have a job where i need to act
professionally so i have all of these
roles that require me to make small
tweaks and changes
and act in certain professional and
different ways that kind of might delude
me into thinking
that i'm somehow more important
than i actually am and i feel as though
whenever i'm around water i tend to
appreciate that i'm just a human being
and nothing that i really do
is that important and the world is so so
beautiful and i can kind of get in touch
with my natural kind of childish inner
self
who i used to be before all of these
things started to happen
so i really appreciate doing that and i
tend to just
love love to be around water whenever i
can for example i'm very fortunate
because in this house um near my bed you
probably can't see it but there's like
the river just there so i can kind of
see the river every morning or and every
night or whatever i have a small break
and especially i love going near the sea
which unfortunately i can't afford
to travel that often but whenever i can
i just love
going near the sea and it just helps me
kind of calm down
relax i'll shut everything off and
forget all of my little problems
issues and deadlines the third thing i
want to mention is mindfulness and
meditation
and this one is a bit challenging and
difficult the reason for that
is that i've always had an issue with
meditation i feel as though in the last
decade i've just seen it mentioned so
much everywhere
and i feel as though it is so so so
difficult for me
because i find it so difficult to switch
off anyway
ever since i've ever been able to think
i've always been overthinking
so i felt as though meditation was not
right for me but also at the same time
because it was so mainstream i thought
why can't i just not do this thing that
everyone seems to be doing
so it took me a lot of practice and
definitely the flotation experiences
have helped
so much with it but i'm currently in a
state where i can actually
stop my mind from thinking and just take
a few minutes to just
think of nothing and meditate i will say
it's very challenging because it takes
me
quite a long time to get into a state of
stopping thinking
takes me maybe half an hour so it's
really not easy for me to do
and i really need to like plan it out
and have that time ready but
i do try to do it every single day and
sometimes even if i'm just lying in bed
i try to kind of breathe in and stop
everything
and um yeah just try to try to meditate
in general
the reason i love meditation is that it
just kind of grounds me to the moment
there's this phrase that i love that
says that one of the stupidities of man
is that they think that they are too
busy to be doing what they're actually
doing
and if we wrap our head around this for
a second it actually makes so much sense
i feel as though i fall into this trap
quite often where i might be studying
something
i'm thinking in my mind oh my god i
can't afford to be doing this right now
i'm too busy i need to be doing this
other studying thing
i don't know if everyone anyone else has
felt this before but it is
actually quite ridiculous to feel as
though you're too busy to be doing
what you're doing so i feel as though
meditating and kind of
doing nothing intentionally all of this
rush and hustle is quite pointless and
the meditation is actually the thing
that i will be looking forward to in the
end of the day also i
feel as though it helps me kind of
lengthen my life and make my experience
of life feel a bit longer i will never
forget the phrases that my parents
sometimes say
which are along the lines of i can't
believe that time has gone so fast
i feel like i was 25 years old yesterday
and now i'm in my 60s
and i always thought how is this
possible but i also kind of sense it
myself
where i think oh my god i feel like i'm
still 22 or still 23 years old
i don't realize that kind of the years
are ticking by and i think that's
because
i'm possibly doing a lot and the more i
do
then the shorter time feels so i feel as
though taking just
an hour a day to meditate will make that
hour feel so much longer than it
actually is
and then therefore that day will feel
longer than it is and the week and the
month and this is kind of the way that i
hope that things work
but i'm just trying to add as much empty
space in my days as i can
because in the end i think those are the
ones that i appreciate the most and
lastly the fourth method is actually the
first one that i discovered
and that is painting i feel like one of
the reasons that i loved painting so
much apart from the fact that i
genuinely enjoy
painting so much is the effect that it
has on my mind
so when i'm painting it's one of those
rare occasions where i'm actually not
thinking of much and for me this is
extremely extremely rare i feel as
though
once i get into the painting i'm in the
state of flow where it's actually my
subconscious mind which is doing the
work and
my conscious mind is left free to roam
and for some reason whenever i'm
painting my conscious mind does not
tend to think about work and studying
and all that stuff but it just tends to
think about
nothing and appreciate the moment and i
remember so clearly when i first got
into this painting flow
as a child how incredible and relieving
and liberating it felt so ever since i
feel as though whenever i'm in
a good state of painting sometimes if
i'm around other people i can use my
conscious mind to
chat but in general when i'm doing
painting on my own which is how i do it
most of the time
it just feels so so so so so great so i
feel as though not only am i kind of
learning a skill and doing something
that i love
and creating beautiful things for myself
to see but also i'm giving myself a huge
break from thinking in general so yes if
you're related to any of these points
you might actually find
my newsletter also quite interesting to
read perhaps
i'll be linking it in my description but
that's the place where i talk about
similar things to
this but yes that's all for today i hope
you have a wonderful day before yourself
and others i don't believe everything
you think thanks
bye